[Music]
Ian Hathaway and Camilla Kibeho the
latest magazine cover stars so cool
Camilla looking majestic on the March /
April issue of latina magazine and she's
getting candid about leaving fifth
harmony quote I needed to follow my
heart and my artistic vision I'm less
focused on success and more on doing my
best obviously any band any group
someday is not going to be together
anymore like that's just you know that's
just yeah that's a life that's just you
know the truth
20 year old also opens up about her
anxieties quote I would wake up with a
super accelerated heartbeat and really
negative intrusive compulsive thoughts I
was so inside my head and I didn't know
what was happening she credits reading
books and her mom for helping her cope
adding she's in a much better place now
and look at Anne Hathaway on the April
2017 cover of Elle she's pretty in pink
and revealing how husband Adam Schulman
changed her quote he changed my ability
to be in the world comfortably I think
they accept a narrative now is that we
as women don't need anybody but I need
my husband
his unique and specific love has changed
me believe me I count my stars her lucky
stars every day
[Music]
you